Hi everyone. I'm here with Dr. Shawn
McDall and definitely wanted to talk to
him because there's an important topic
that uh was very crucial in my becoming
a Christian and yet certain elements
have been called into question. So lots
of you know that I grew up as an atheist
uh and not just a normal atheist, an
atheist with antisocial personality
disorder and that is a good recipe for
ending up in jail. So, I ended up in
jail. And while I was in jail, I met a
very interesting Christian. He was a guy
who turned himself in for 21 felonies.
We got into a series of conversations.
And up until then, I had always thought
that I had successfully explained the
origin of Christianity. I knew that uh
early Christians were going around
preaching that Jesus rose from the dead.
I thought I had an explanation for that.
And the obvious explanation to me was
Jesus had followers. Jesus died. and his
followers wanted to keep the movement
going and so what better way to do that
than make up a story about your guy
rising from the dead. So that made sense
to me. Uh but as I was having
discussions with Randy, I don't even
remember what led into this, but he
started talking about how the apostles
died and he gave me a copy of Fox's book
of martyrs and going through the
descriptions in Fox's book of martyrs.
Uh a kind of problem arose. So let me
just give a couple quick quotations
here. So gives a list of the apostles
and other early Christians and starts
explaining how they died. So Philip it
says he was scourged, thrown in prison
and afterwards crucified AD54. So pretty
pretty uh good information there. Gives
even gives a date. Uh Matthew the scene
of his labors was Partha and Ethiopia in
which latter country he suffered
martyrdom being slain uh in the city of
Nabada in AD60. We've got uh James, the
son of Zebedee. Uh James, the brother of
Jesus. Uh it says at the age of 94, he
was beaten, stoned by the Jews and
finally had his brains dashed out with a
Fuller's club. It keeps going. Matias,
Andrew, Mark, Peter, giving the details
of how they died. And it's martyr,
martyr, martyr, martyr, martyr up until
you get to John and then it says uh he
was not uh martyed with the rest of
them. So these are the kinds of things
that I was reading and I instantly saw
the problem for my
theory. My theory was that these guys
and made up a story. But here they were
being martyed for a story that if I was
right they made up. And I tried to think
of anyone else in history who died for
something that he knew he had made up.
And I couldn't think of one person. And
then I thought, well, even if there was
one person, what are the odds that Jesus
got all of the lunatics of history who
were willing to die for something they
made up? So, it called into question my
entire theory and I realized what I was
saying was not the best explanation of
the evidence. Uh, I ordinarily would
have had a commitment to naturalism. So,
I would have had to have gone with
something like hallucinations, but I was
also wrestling at the same time with a
kind of design argument and a moral
argument. And it it was enough to shake
my confidence in naturalism where I
wasn't presupposing that anymore. And so
I was just looking at all the evidence
and thinking, okay, Jesus died. These
guys were really convinced that he'd
appeared. What could have caused that
level of confidence to where they were
willing to endure torture and death? And
seemed like the best, most obvious
explanation was a man had risen from the
dead. And so I became a Christian and
went around sharing my reasoning. At
first I thought I invented that. I
thought I invented that that response to
the disciples being liars. Turns out
other people had been thinking about
that and realized that and arguing that
long before me among them uh Sean's dad.
So I found out other people had come up
with this before me but was quite happy
to share how I became a Christian and
the role this played. um it went by a
long time, but I started picking up over
the years that some of the sources that
this information was based on and these
claims are based on is significantly
less reliable than other uh other
sources. And so um started modifying how
I describe it over the years, but still
still had a lot of confidence in the the
core and the core argument. And then I
guess nine or 10 years ago, I saw Sean
give a presentation on this and uh I
understand that he's even modified his
position a bit since then. But very
recently, very recently, um got a
challenge from a Muslim named Fared and
he saw this part of my testimony video
and said this.
You guys
know why David
Wood is a
Christian? You guys ever wondered why?
Because he used to be an atheist. You
know why he's a Christian? It's because
of this. Roll the clip.
Yehmedi clip.
Get out of the clip. Roll the clip. I
found out how Jesus apostles died. Most
of them went to their bloody deaths
claiming that they had seen him risen
from the dead.
My explanation for the origin of
Christianity had always been that the
apostles made up a story so that they
could spread his message. But now my
explanation wasn't making sense. If
you're willing to die for something, you
have to believe it. When a terrorist
blows himself up, he's obviously
sincere. So the disciples, the apostles
had to believe what they were dying for.
But this means that they were they were
convinced that they had seen Jesus risen
from the dead. Now, usually when someone
is willing to lay down their life for
something, it's for an ideology that
they got from someone else. And that
ideology could be true or false. The
disciples were dying for something that
they
saw. What could have convinced so many
different people that they had all seen
a resurrected
man? I could explain one witness by
saying he's crazy, but all of
them something was going on here. and I
had to figure it out. But I couldn't
come up with any explanation for why
they had that level of confidence other
than they actually saw
him. David Woods put out over a thousand
videos in the past few years. Not a
single video about this subject. Not a
single video about the disciples being
put to death for preaching the
resurrection.
Why aren't you doing this,
David? If you put this out, maybe we'll
become kufur. Don't you want that? So,
put this video out or tell your people,
tell your fan
base,
why aren't you making a video about the
subject? All right. So, Fared, our good
Muslim friend, wants to know why I
haven't made a video about the deaths of
the apostles. I talked about it in a lot
of videos, but specifically on that
topic, and I thought, well, there's
someone who's much more knowledgeable
about this than I am. So, here I am with
Dr. Shawn McDall, who literally wrote
the book on the fate of the apostles.
So, how you doing, Sean? I'm doing
great. I we sat down probably 10 years
ago and talked about this. So I've been
looking forward to balling up and having
this conversation. Yeah. And so the the
question on my mind is of all the topics
you could get into, why did you want to
focus on destroying everyone's
confidence in Fox's book of martyrs when
we were all perfectly happy with it. So
we'll go back to 2010 and I had started
a PhD program doing my classes but
didn't yet have a topic. So, it's in the
back of my mind. And I'm teaching high
school full-time before I'm at Biola and
Talbot. And we were at Berkeley of all
places, and we bring in some atheists
and Unitarian reverends and LGBTQ
activists to speak to our high school
kids. We teach them about how to defend
their faith graciously. And we had a a
mythicist who denies that Jesus existed
at all, making his claim. Just what
what's a mythicist for everyone? So, a
mythicist would be somebody who denies
the existence of Jesus entirely.
So he's presenting to our students and
one of my students says something effect
of if Jesus didn't exist why would all
the disciples die as
martyrs? And this guy looks at us and he
goes die as martyrs. He goes there's no
good evidence that any of them did. And
my students kind of looked at me and I'm
thinking huh I've made this argument.
I've never really looked into it. Jay
Warner, Wallace, cold case detective,
former atheist, was there. His daughter
was on the trip. And I'm like, Jim, you
think this is a good topic? He goes,
"Not only is it a good topic, but I just
bought two boxes of books and was going
to dive into this myself. You can have
the books. Go for it." Now, two boxes of
books is a drop in the bucket of what
you need to do for a doctoral
dissertation. But right away, I was
like, I'm really interested in this. Uh,
I can make a contribution to the church.
this is a good topic and I can probably
publish this and help people. So, it was
just instant decision at that moment.
And so, obviously, if you're doing a
doctoral dissertation on the fate of the
apostles, you can't walk in there and
say, "Here's what I read in my
apologetics book." So, you got to go
back to the sources. So, how would a
historical investigation of this issue
look as far as what contrast it from
what people are normally used to? Yeah.
So there are scholars that would look at
individual apostles like Marcus Bachmule
and Bacham Peter. There's others that
look at John, but nobody brought all of
them together systematically with a
carefully laid out grid of historical
probability. Instead, I'm going to
assess the quantity and quality of the
evidence for the apostles. Number one,
see if this argument actually works. And
if it does, what's the strongest way to
formulate it? So, I didn't go into this
trying to defend the deaths of the
apostles in this argument. You can't do
that in a doctoral dissertation. I
believed it, but I went into it saying,
"What is the evidence? How early is it?
How many sources do we have? How
reliable are these?" And my adviser made
me do an entire chapter, which was just
months of research on how do we do
historical methodology? Has
postmodernism refuted the idea that we
can have historical knowledge? And so I
laid out a 10point probability scale
from highest probability to least
probability to kind of indeterminate in
the middle. And then just took each
apostle one by one, found every source I
could have, analyzed them as deeply as I
could and try to come up with what I
think is the best historical
representation of the likelihood of the
way that they died. So, as far as a a
historical investigation, um again, lots
of lots of Christians would just, you
know, read an apologetics book or
something like that and and see it. If
you're if you're doing a historical
investigation, so you'd be looking for
how early your sources are. Do you have
independent sources covering these kinds
of things? Um that that sort of thing.
Yeah, that's right. And by the way, I
I'll it's kind of embarrassing to admit
this, but I will. Is the book More Than
a Carpenter? I helped my dad update in
2009. I uh started my PhD in 2010 and we
list out the traditional deaths of the
apostles and we put the world's most
vague and worst footnote in the history
of footnotes in the back of that book.
It says something effect of to see how
they died. See church history. So you
remember this. I at that moment there
was a seed of like huh what is that? I'm
sure somebody knows. It was one of the
seeds that intrigued me in this. So
clearly we have not looked at this as
carefully as we need to. And as I
shifted from like apologist making that
case to like historian and like you said
the number of sources, the reliability
of the sources, the bias of the sources,
the copying of these sources. You got to
delve into all of that and I did as best
I could with each of the apostles. And
little side note, an old man gave me
more than a carpenter in prison. And
that was the first apologetics book I
read where I knew I was reading
apologetics because I had seen the book
in the apologetics category of the
Christian book distributors catalog and
I was like, "Oh, that's the book that's
in the apologetics category." But an old
man came up to me and he said, "Uh, my
daughter sent me this. Looks like
something you'd be interested in." And I
I read that and I was like, "Oh, this is
exactly what I'm interested in." So, and
and by the way, we updated that in a
recent edition and I think I nuanced in
a way that's more reflective of the
evidence just for the record. All right.
So if you're doing historical
investigation, there are uh lots of
first century sources, both Christian
and non-Christian, second century
sources, third century sources, and so
on. Um, so you kind of have to narrow
down your focus. So who did you focus on
and and why did you pick those guys?
Well, I tried to look
at Marcus Bachmile has what he calls the
living memory within the first two
centuries. So it's kind of like I can,
you know, my grandpa was born in 1898.
So my dad can tell me stories about his
grandpa and there's still kind of a
living memory tracing back that far. So
within roughly to about 8200, I tried to
favor those sources because they have a
higher degree of reliability. That
doesn't mean everything in that period
is reliable and everything out of it is
not. But I tried to favor the sources
within that period. Now, obviously, I'm
going to take the twel apostles, except
Judas is replaced by Matias. And then I
decided to go with Paul because he
writes 13 letters of the New Testament.
Even critical scholars would admit
seven. And he says he's seen the risen
Jesus multiple times. And then James,
the brother of Jesus. We have an account
of his appearance in 1 Corinthians 15.
And we also know that he spent time with
Paul when Paul comes to Jerusalem quite
presumably and obviously to confirm that
his role in the early early church
likely authorship of the book of James
felt like there was a weight with them.
Could have studied Luke could have added
Mark. You got to limit your study
somewhere and my initial take was those
seem clearly later in legendary. So
bottom line, 12 disciples and then James
the brother of Jesus and the Apostle
Paul. And the uh this is kind of a side
note, but it's it's closely connected
the the issue of persecution in the
early church because the main the the
main relevance as far as the my thinking
was and and the thinking of other people
is that the willingness of the apostles
to endure martyrdom showed that they
were sincere in their belief and that
they're not just simply making things
up. they're at least taking it
seriously. Um, but persecution would
kind of make the same argument. So, even
if they had all even if they all had
lived completely full and satisfying
lives or something like that, um, if
they had endured
persecution for their beliefs, Yeah.
then it would sort of serve the same
role. So, I'm just wondering as far as
the sources go, uh, the status of
persecution in the early church, we've
heard of, you know, the persecution, um,
from Emperor Nero and stuff like that,
but, uh, is that also in question or
so if there was no persecution, it
doesn't mean they didn't die as martyrs.
People can be killed for their faith
even if there's not a systemwide
persecution. But it creates a certain
millu and expectation and maybe
likelihood that supports individual
cases of martyrdom. Now, I think we make
two mistakes. I think there's some
Christians, in fact, yesterday I was
talking to one who's like, "From the
moment that Christians became believers,
there was this
nonstop kind of, you know, empirewide
persecution against Christians." I'm
like, "That is overstated." But there's
also been some people like Candida Moss
who I argue has gone the other direction
and undermined the evidence we have that
at least it cost something for
Christians whether we call it
persecution or not to proclaim the
living Jesus. And by the way the issue
was not that they said Jesus was God.
It's that the Christians would not also
sacrifice to the local deities which was
viewed as harming the empire. That was
the issue. Now, if you start in the New
Testament, it was kind of a this is a
remarkable experience for me, David. I'd
encourage people watching this is I just
read through the entire New Testament at
least two times. And I noted every
single time it made an indication that a
follower of Jesus, it will cost them
something for doing it. And I was like
taken back at how much I missed it. It's
like a golden thread through almost all
of the New Testament. Of course, it's in
the Gospels. It's in the letters of
Paul. Clearly like Philippians, he's
writing likely from jail. Hebrews, it's
all over Hebrews. The hall of faith in
Hebrews chapter 11, it's in the book of
James chapter 5 in particular. Of
course, Revelation. So you have multiple
attestation in number, but also
multiplication in the kind like letter,
apocryphal, gospel. And then you get
outside and you of course you have in
115 Tacitus is writing and he reports
that the Christians are kind of used as
a scapegoat for the fire of Rome to get
Nero clear of these charges. But we know
this writing was not invented by
Christians because the way Christians
are depicted like is they're hated for
these terrible things that they do is
not what Christians would make up. But
what's interesting about that is it's
tied to the name of Jesus, the kind of
persecution that they're experiencing.
Now, that was just in Rome, but if this
take place in Rome, you could say that
there's precedent in the rest of the
empire for doing so. And we see that in
other instances as well. So I don't want
to overstate it but clearly we have
reason to believe that it costs
Christians to proclaim this faith from
the text but also outside in Nero and
then as you go later in the writings of
Planet the Younger etc.
All right. And now uh as far as
something like Fox's book of martyrs,
it's uh just stating these martyrdoms as
facts, but um again, some of the sources
are significantly less reliable than
others. So, and and to be to be fair,
it's always possible that a late source
is correct. Maybe it was drawing on
earlier material and we just don't have
that anymore. And but that means we we
kind of can't know. We can't we can't
know if we uh if we don't have something
reliable that that person was basing it
on. So when you actually do historical
investigation, take into account um when
the sources are from um and how many
sources you have and the quality of the
sources and so on, you end up breaking
things down into four categories deter
uh based on based on how much confidence
we can have in what's going on. So the
group that probably most people are
interested in, you break them down, you
break down the apostles into four
groups. The group that most people are
probably most interested in is you have
a group where the people on your list
have a very high probability of having
been martyed based on information. So uh
clarify that category and tell us who's
in it. Sure. So I would put four
apostles in that. Two of the 12 which
would be Peter and James the son of
Zebedee and then James the brother of
Jesus and Paul. So of the 12, I think
only two are in the highest level of
historical probability or close to it.
So if we break this down, Peter for
example, there's two first century
sources, John 21 and 1 Clement 5. And
Bart Urman writes that at least these
are sources that the writer is aware of
a tradition of the execution of Peter.
Two first century sources. And then
depending how you assess the sources,
there's probably between six and eight
more sources in the second century, all
within that living memory that
unanimously and consistently portray
that Peter died as a martyr. I find no
good reason to doubt Peter. I put him in
the highest level. I I put Paul one one
one side note because it's in everyone's
head from Fox's book of martyrs. Peter
is supposed to have suffered martyrdom
at Rome during the reign of the emperor
Nero being crucified with his head
downward at his own request.
So you mentioned that we have the
sources on Peter and that you have a
high degree of confidence that he was
martyed. Yep. Is it in this specific way
or Okay. So Fox's book of martyrs, the
last thing he said is at his own
request. Let me ask you a question,
David. Do you think the Romans were in
the business of taking requests about
how you wanted to be crucified?
Part of me says no, but I've known some
uh sick prison guards who if I would
say, "No, I don't want that punishment."
They'd be like, "Oh, you want something
else?" "Oh, okay." So, I can actually I
don't think I wouldn't say it's likely,
but I can imagine someone going, "Oh,
you don't want to be crucified the same
way? Let us come up with something
creative for you." So, so fair enough.
There are some examples of people being
crucified upside down. As a whole, the
Romans were not invested in trying to
kill you the way you wanted to die. It
was to humiliate and punish you in the
way they thought best made that example.
Could there be a possible exception?
Sure. But the first time we have Peter
being crucified upside down is in the
Acts of Peter, which is an apocryphal
text written about 180 or 190 AD. Now, I
think there's a historical core to this,
but you don't have the request and the
sense of worthiness until appearing
later in church fathers that start
picking this up in the third and fourth
century. But if you read the first
account, Peter's upside down. I think a
better understanding is he's upside down
because the world is turned upside down.
And when he's upside down, he can see
the world as it is. And Peter's death,
like the death of Jesus, can help turn
the world right side up. There's a
theological reason behind it, as there
is in a lot of the apocryphal acts,
rather than a historical one. Now, with
that said, one of the areas that I've
shifted is I thought Peter was
crucified, but not upside down. But then
a book came out months after my 2015 the
first account of the fate of the
apostles edited by Larry Herertado and
there's a chapter in there and he
described that one thing we know about
crucifixion again in the vast majority
of cases although there might be some
exceptions is that somebody was stripped
bare the idea was to humiliate and shame
them yet in John 21 what does Jesus tell
Peter you will be taken where you do not
want to go. You will be
clothed by another. That's enough to
give me pause and go, "Oh, I think maybe
he experienced in the death of Nero,
people had these flammable kinds of
clothes that were put on to be burned to
death." I think that's probably more
likely. Bottom line, whether he was
crucified upside down or crucified at
all, that doesn't undermine our
confidence that Peter died as a martyr,
which is the heart of my task. So,
martyrdom, yes. Uh, not not nearly
enough to go on to say something about
uh dying crucified upside down. Yeah, I
would say not even not enough to go on.
I think the weight is against it. Okay.
But fair enough. Um, all right. So, next
you were going with Paul. Okay. So Paul,
not one of the 12, but calls himself an
apostle because he saw the risen Jesus.
We have one reliable first century
source. Some would point towards Acts
and they could indicate a way that it's
indicating he was going to be martyed.
You could point towards the passage in
Timothy where he says, "I fought the,
you know, good fight, finished the
race." If that's not written actually by
Paul, some people argue second Timothy.
They were aware that he was about to die
as a martyr. Like we don't have to
settle that one. But I think the first
century we have first clement five one
clear reliable first century source
compared to P that has two second
century we probably have more like six
to eight sources so a little bit less
than Paul but it's early it's unanimous
it's consistent I find no good reason to
doubt that Paul died as a martyr now
Peter I put highest possible probability
Paul I put very probably true just to
try to be careful on my scale
But we have high confidence Paul died as
a martyr. The other two James I would
put quickly. James the brother of Jesus.
I'm sorry. Let's go with James the son
of Zebedee. We had this account in Acts
12. It's one of the only two accounts of
their deaths we have in the scriptures.
Peter, John 21, James, Acts 12:2. Well,
a lot of this relies upon the
historicity of the book of Acts, which
is beyond what we can go into now, but I
think there's a strong case for it
historically. We also have the reference
Ken writes in his commentary when Herod
agria, the grandson of Herod the Great,
kills him. It's just it reads like an
execution account. It's not flowery.
There's no legend in it. And it says
that this Herod did it to please the
Jews. You find confirmation that Herod
Agrippa had that kind of posture towards
the Jews unlike Herod the Great in
Josephus. So there's kind of this
coincidence that incidentally supports
it and then all the later accounts that
I could find line up with James dying in
this fashion. So I had him originally at
highest possible probability. Put him
down once since we only have one source
for it. But again, no good reason to
doubt that. James, a brother of Jesus.
What's interesting about this is he's
the only apostle for which we have
Gnostic, Christian, and Jewish sources.
We have Josephus in the '9s. We have
Christian sources like when you get into
the second century, Giannis of Corinth.
And then you have like the first and
second apocalypse of James somewhere in
the second, third century, possibly one
of is even later, all pointing towards
his martyrdom. I actually raised my
confidence in James because I found some
scholarly journals pushing back on this.
And I spent time reading them and
engaging with scholars and when it was
done, I thought their arguments so don't
work. I'm more convinced he died as a
martyr than before. People can read the
book for the details, but I think those
four were in very solid ground saying
they died as martyrs. And uh I I think
the the the fourman lineup there is uh
is interesting and that you have two
followers of Jesus. And then you have
Paul who's a persecutor of the early
church and then uh James at least
according to the gospels is uh not
terribly confident that his brother is
the Messiah at first and then later on
becomes a leader in the early church.
and you try to figure out why Paul and
James had such a radical shift and
you're stuck with the resurrection
because that's uh that's what that's
what the claim was back then. I just
wanted to uh connect this one more to
once more to persecution. You're talking
about the Apostle Paul, but we have from
his own hand some of the descriptions of
what this was like. Um but here in uh
here uh let me pull it up. 2 Corinthians
11. Yeah. He says, yeah, he says, uh,
five, verse 24 of chapter 11, five times
I received from the Jews the 40 lashes
minus one. Three times I was beaten with
rods. Once I was pelted with stones,
three times I was shipwrecked. I spent a
night and a day in the open sea. I have
been constantly on the move. I have been
in danger from rivers, in danger from
bandits, in danger from my fellow Jews,
in danger from Gentiles, in danger in
the city, in danger in the country, in
danger at sea, and in danger from false
believers. I have labored and toiled and
have often gone without sleep. I have
known hunger and thirst and have often
gone without food. I have been cold and
naked. Uh besides everything else, I
face daily the pressure of my concern
for all the churches. And so uh Paul
definitely went through a lot of
persecution and he points out that he's
been persecuted more than uh most
others. But uh also in in first
Corinthians, he puts like the the
apostles in that category of being what
he he he he calls like we're the scum of
the earth and that's how we're treated.
And so it wasn't uh it wasn't an issue
of uh become an apostle. It's a great
life for the Apostle Paul. And so uh and
in addition to that, you're concluding
that he was most uh likely martyed. So
those are the guys you put in the sort
of highest category probability wise.
And for people who are thinking, why are
you talking about you know probabilities
and stuff like that? Well, that's how
history that's how history works, right?
That's exactly right. Dealing with
ancient sources. You have to figure out
the best explanation for the evidence.
Okay. So, uh that's the highest
category. But the next category uh would
be
apostles who kind of seem like they died
as martyrs, but the evidence isn't as
strong as it is for Peter, Paul, and the
the two Jameses. I would put two in this
category. I'd put Thomas. And scholars
are all over the map with Thomas from
most confident to least confidence.
Eastern scholars tend to be very
confident that Thomas died as a martyr.
I for Thomas the earliest source now is
what's called the Acts of Thomas. Now
you're at 200 to 220 AD. So it's a book
that has some legendary content in it,
although I think it maintains a
historical core, but it's also pushing
that living memory boundary.
If that's all we had, I'd probably
conclude that it's inconclusive. But we
also have the traditions of the St.
Thomas Christians who don't have an
early written record, but they have
poems and they have stories and they
have songs and traditions and arguably
the burial spot going all the way back
to the time that Thomas founded the
church in India. It seems to me that
those are independent. Somebody needs to
do a doctoral dissertation comparing
those two traditions and seeing if we
can answer that definitively because if
the St. Thomas Christians totally rely
upon the Acts of Thomas, we have one
source. If it's separate, we have two. I
tend to think it's two, but we need a
deep dive on that. Bottom line, for
those first four, if somebody said, "Are
you willing to bet your house that they
died as martyr?" I'd be like, "Game on.
Let's bet it." These I only would do so
if forced to bet my house. I'd say, "All
right, I'm going to land on the side of
Thomas, but with a lot less confidence
in the others." Andrew, we have two
sources. Acts of Andrew in in probably
in the second century, and then we have
a later writing, maybe early third,
called Hippolitis on the 12. Both
describe his crucifixion in very
different ways that seem independent. So
I put that as like more plausible than
not maybe like
51% minimal confidence you could have
but if I had to bet in my house two
moderate sources no contradictory
accounts probably those two died as
martyrs and it's uh I've met some of the
Christians from the area uh Thomas
they're they they that's how they
explain themselves they we got this we
got this from Thomas and uh it's part of
their identity for sure and it goes back
early. Now, you mentioned someone doing
a doctoral dissertation on the topic.
Would be cool. Would be cool for someone
from that community to do that. I love
it. Or somebody outside the community.
So, you have these two categories. Then
you have the the third category, which
is what I don't know what you call it.
I'll call it the we don't have enough
evidence to go on to make any
conclusions category. But who'd be in
this? Well, so you have these early
acts, Acts of Peter, Acts of Paul, Acts
of John that I think maintain a basic
historical core. When you get to like
the 4th century, these acts seem to be
completely unhinged from history. And so
for like Bartholomew, Simon the Zealot,
Matias,
uh, Thaddius, these figures, all we have
are these writings way removed about
their martyrs. You don't find anything
for example in Ucius about their deaths
and some of them just seem so legend
fililled like Bartholomew if I remember
I think I found maybe five different
ways according to these stories that he
died I mean he was flay to death he was
crucified he was killed with arrows he
was drowned death he was burned to death
either they're all made up or one is
true but if one is true I don't know how
to decipher them if you look at an
ancient picture of Bartholomew in a
church or there's a statue he'll be
standing in there typically holding his
skin. The story is he was skinned alive.
The earliest source I could find I think
was about 600 AD for that. Now that
doesn't mean it's false but how much
historical confidence can be put in
that? Now I study I had to get books and
study like what did skinning entail? Did
it exist at this time? And some of this
was like morbid actually to read. I did
I did not enjoy that. But skinning was
practiced and it could have happened to
him. I just don't think we have any good
early evidence to conclude. So those I
think I put five in that category. I
just don't think if we're looking at
this historically, we know. And by the
way, just last week someone was someone
was from the Armenian church and they
were talking about the stories of
Bartholomew. There's some traditions who
went there, Andrew, and they're like,
"Sean said none of these are true." And
I said, "I'm not trying to rain on
anybody's party and destroy traditions.
I just want to know historically what
can we actually conclude about the
stories of their deaths. That's an
important point because if you're
talking about what you can confirm
historically, most things that have ever
happened you can't confirm historically.
You have to have you have to have s you
have to have reliable sources telling
you these things happen and so on. So
some if someone has a tradition for
their church or something like that
doesn't mean it it didn't happen. You
just if you're approaching it as a
historian saying can I confirm this from
a from the perspective of a historian.
Exactly. Yeah. All right. So then
there's the fourth category of people
who died natural deaths, apostles who
died natural deaths. And according to
Fox's book of martyrs, there was just
John. There was just John. What do you
think? So I put three in this category.
Now when I started, a few things
surprised me. I went into it assuming
what Fox's book of martyrs said that
likely they died as martyrs and John
didn't. My assumption was that was
probably true, but had to look at the
evidence. I was surprised to find some
scholars like Ben Witherington and
Richard Bacham who make the case
biblically and extra biblically that
John died as a martyr. Since my first
publication, there's been another
writing by Dean Furlong. He makes this
case that John died as a martyr. Part of
me is like, "Wow, if I could get more,
that would make my case stronger." But
of course, I've got to follow where I
think the evidence leads. And they'll
point to things like, I think it's in
Mark chapter 10 where Jesus says, you
know, disciples are walking with Jesus,
James and John, can you drink the cup
that I'm about to drink? Well, in many
cases, drinking the cup is martyrdom. We
have James in Acts 12 dying as a martyr.
That's kind of biblical evidence. You
have John all at the beginning of Acts
and then disappearing and not showing up
at the Jerusalem Council. Why? Because
he was martyed is the argument that they
make. You have church calendars
appearing I think the earliest maybe the
fourth century in the 300s and you have
this quote by Philip of Ceday in the
fifth century a church historian that
refers to the martyrdom of John. I'm not
convinced by that case as a whole. For
example, when I talk to experts on
Philip of Ceday, that quote is probably
not original to Philip of Ceday. I don't
think we can trust it. I don't think the
cup necessarily has to be martyrdom.
Although, I suspect that some people
like Tertullan might have invented John
going through the boiling oil and
surviving to fulfill that as what he
thought was a prophecy. Maybe. I can't
prove that, but I suspect it. So, I
still think John died naturally. Uh, and
I'd love to be convinced, but I'm just
not persuaded by it. Where I really
shifted, what which I think is
interesting, David, is on Matthew. So,
Matthew, I concluded, was indeterminate.
We couldn't know because I found
traditions that were in favor of
martyrdom and against it. Published this
in my 2015 book. A French scholar reach
out reaches out to me. He goes, "Sean, I
don't know what translation of Clement
of Alexandria you're reading." And I'm
like, "The antyine fathers, the typical
English edition." He goes, "If you go
back to the original Greek, which is
earlier, there's a negation that's not
in the English." Now, you and I know a
no or a not literally flips the meaning
of something. And so, I couldn't just
take his word for it. I checked with a
few other early scholars. I'm like,
"Which is early? Which is reliable?" And
I think he's right about this. So if you
go to this passage in Clement of
Alexandria in middle 2 century, he's
he's quoting someone named Heracleion
who refers to four apostles who I
thought was saying died as martyrs. I
think what he's saying is he's making a
distinction between those who confess
the faith and die and those who confess
the faith and die because they've
confessed the faith. And I think the
clear indication is once I read it with
this negation in context was saying that
these four actually died natural deaths.
So when I look at that there's a second
early source for the natural death of
Matthew which is in Hippolitis on the 12
I believe that is and then you don't
have an account of the martyrdom of
Matthew until the fifth century. So the
earliest accounts have him dying
naturally and then you have later
accounts of him some dying naturally
some dying as a martyr. So I flipped on
Matthew and I think he probably died
naturally. Philip I'm really close on
this one because Philip is also cited by
Heracleion in Clement of Alexandria as
dying
naturally. Uh and then the earliest
martr for Philip is in the acts of
Philip when I think the acts are
unhinged from history in the 4th century
and then later traditions have both. So
I don't know if I bet my house on
Matthew or not. I'd have to think about
that. I think he probably died
naturally. If forced to, I would say
that Philillip did, but it's still, and
here's why. That source in
Clement, he mentions Thomas dying that
way, too. But I don't think Thomas died
that way. So, I think he probably got
Thomas wrong. He doesn't mention John
dying naturally. Well, why not mention
John? So, it raises some questions that
we just I don't know how to answer those
questions. And this is the task of a
historian to say okay what source do we
have how reliable is it where did this
source gives information can we confirm
it in the case of Matthew we have a few
early sources he died naturally so I
think Matthew probably died naturally so
I put three in that category David and a
number of other historians I looked into
it actually assess it pretty similar to
that as well uh such as Brian Litin in
his book after acts which is a great
popular book of the fate of the apostles
So you've got uh you've got four
categories based on what you can
determine historically. Uh the highest
evidence we have for martyrdoms you
would apply to Peter, Paul, James, son
of Zebedee, and James the brother of
Jesus. Yep. Then you have seems more
probable than not, but not the same
evidence that you have for those
original four. And you put Thomas and
Andrew in that category. Yep. And then
you have a category just indeterminate.
We don't know natural death, martyrdom.
We don't have enough information to go
on. And then uh you have three that you
would say evidence leans towards these
guys just dying natural deaths. Yeah. To
to different degrees. I think John
pretty high, Matthew moderately high,
Philip minimally high. All right. So
that's that would be your position in
contrast with Fox's book of martyrs. So,
we have to decide who who we're going to
believe here. But we want to cover a
couple of couple of objections here.
Cover a couple of objections. So, um
this is kind of a strange one to me
because when I thought about it, I I
understood this in like two seconds.
Okay. Like I understood instantly as
soon as I realized how these guys died.
Um that they are in a different category
from people who are willing to die for
what they believe today. They're in a
different category from most people who
die for what they believe. People die
for what they believe all the time.
Um, and so you say, okay, the apostles
obviously believed what they were dying
for, believed what they were being
persecuted for, and so you would
conclude therefore they can't it makes
no sense to think that they're uh that
they're making something up
deliberately. But inst just instantly
instantly people will start saying,
well, what about uh, you know, what
about the 9/11 attackers and stuff? Does
this mean that Islam is true? What about
this? Does that mean that's true? What
about Buddhists who die for what they
believe in? Does that mean it's true?
And so, how about you clarify what
you're actually saying for for people? I
was in a bed and breakfast in I think
Missouri and a nun. I was having
breakfast with a nun and she started
grilling me on this while I was doing my
research. I always think of this when
someone raises this question because
it's a good one. It's the natural
objection that people raise. I'd say two
things. There are martyrs in other
faiths and belief systems. I would not
call the 9/11 uh hijackers martyrs. I
call them murderers because they are
taking the life of other people rather
than willingly laying down their life at
the hand or sword of another. But
nonetheless, they died for what they
believed and were willing to give their
lives for it. We had Buddhist monks
light themselves on fire, kamicazi
pilots for the cause. So there's other
martyrs. We actually have second Mcabes.
We have the Makabian martyrs willing to
lay down their lives. The question we
have to ask is why. So Makabian martyrs
refuse to
compromise the law. The Buddhist monks
do this in Vietnam because they were
protesting it. The apostles were willing
to suffer and die because they believed
that Jesus had risen from the grave. I
have a whole chapter on this where I had
to get to the origin and the earliest
beliefs that were proclaimed about
Christianity because we hear about these
gnostic gospels and there was diversity
in the early church whether it's in the
creeds the preaching in Acts the early
church fathers there is no early
Christianity apart from the claim that
Jesus is God and he's demonstrated by
raising from the grave. So, they're
willing to suffer and die because they
believe Jesus had risen from the grave
and appeared to them. Now, if somebody
walks in here right now and asks the two
of us, "Do you believe Jesus is the
risen savior and we die for the cause?"
By the way, if one of us is going to die
for the cause, I have a feeling it's
going to more likely be you, but maybe
these are famous last words for a
separate issue.
But if they walk in here right now, all
that proves is, well, Sean and David
really believe this. But there's nothing
evidentially significant whatsoever for
Christianity tied to our beliefs because
we are 2,000 years removed from it. But
the apostles were there. They claimed to
have seen the risen Jesus. That puts
them in a different epistemic position,
you might say. And what we know about
this relies upon their testimony. Now,
their willingness to suffer and die
doesn't prove that Christianity is true.
I don't think in principle it overturns
the hallucination hypothesis. We can
handle that on different grounds, but
they're not making this up. They
minimally really believe that Jesus
appeared to them and they're willing to
suffer and die for it. So, we know the
early Christians are going around
preaching Jesus is Lord and that he died
on the cross and rose from the dead. and
we're looking for the best explanation
for why they're making that claim. One
of the possible explanations of people
going around saying a guy rose from the
dead and appeared to us. One possible
explanation would be that they're lying.
Yep. And so this is meant to block that
objection. They do not seem like liars.
They seem very sincere. And even when
you look at other that's what they would
have in common with other people who are
dying for what they believe. I do not
question the sincerity of confidence in
Islam of the 911 hijackers. I don't
either. I believe that they were
completely sincere. I don't believe
they're like, "Uh, hey, you know what? I
don't believe Islam. Let me go do this.
I don't believe that." Um, so it's a it
shows that someone is sincere. And you
could have other examples of this that
have nothing to do with it. If uh if
someone walks in here and says, "I
believe aliens exist." And I say, "Okay,
why do you believe that?" And it's like,
"Well, look at the the universe is big."
And so on. I'd say, "Okay, then you
know, you're inferring that from, you
know, the size of the universe and just
probability or something like that." If
someone tells me he saw an alien, I
would be wondering, "Are you making
things up?" If someone put a gun to his
head and said, "Amit that you didn't see
any aliens." And he said, "I saw the
aliens. I don't care what you do to me."
I would think, "Okay, at the very least,
he believes he believes he has seen an
alien." That wouldn't convince me that
he has seen an alien, but I would not
believe that he's making that up if he's
willing to die for it. And that then the
question would become what gave this guy
this level of confidence in this claim?
What could have convinced this guy? And
if it's one guy, you might be saying
hallucinations, something like that. If
you had all kinds of people, then I have
to start thinking, what's going on here?
What's going on? If you had a bunch of
people making the same kinds of claims,
uh, and so that's the situation we're in
with the apostles. If it were just one
guy saying Jesus had risen from the
dead, maybe hallucinations, you have a
bunch of guys and they're willing to
endure persecution and death. It's kind
of in a different category as you
pointed out from me and you me or you
dying today. And that's right. And by
the way, it's the 12 that we have, but
we also have Paul and James outside of
that group. And the vast majority
scholars, as Hobber Moss points out,
believe at least they report that they
had seen the risen Jesus. And so any
explanation got to account for all
those. The disciples were lying. How do
you get James and how do you get Paul on
board? This is the other problems that
emerge. Yeah. And yeah, that that's kind
of what it becomes again. If if it's one
guy, you could explain by hallucination.
Two guys, it starts getting a little
weird. If the more people you have
hallucinating,
um the more you're kind of stretching
how much work this uh this theory is
doing. Once you start factoring in
people who weren't even part of the
group, and then it's like, what are the
odds that Jesus got all the
hallucinators uh around him at that
time? that they're they're they're all
hallucinating. Very strange stuff. Um,
so that's one objection that people
often have. There's another one that
would come up here and that would be
we're talking about the the apostles
dying for what they believed in their
belief that Jesus is Lord and that he
rose from the dead. Um, but as you
pointed out, some of the some of the
records of what happened to these guys
are pretty shaky. So, how would we know
that Peter wasn't about to be crucified?
He's like, "Okay, I take it all back."
And they're like, "Too late. Too late.
You're locked in now." Okay, that's
fair. So, this is actually in the back
of the updated book, I added like six
new objections. And this is one of the
objections. And so, I went to a church
historian that I work with at Talbot and
a few others. And I said, "Is there
precedent to believe that if a Christian
or an apostle said, "Oh, wait. I recant
they would survive." And he goes, "Well,
let's look at ply the younger who was
saying they were worshiping Jesus as if
he was a god. And if they recanted, they
were allowed to leave. In fact, they
were given multiple chances. It seems
like like please just recant this. We
don't want to kill you." Is almost the
vibe that you get a little bit into the
third century. It's the case that you
see multiple cases of Christians if
they're willing to say, you know what, I
don't believe this. They were able to go
on with their lives and not be martyed.
So I think there's doubt that they still
would have been killed against their
wills. But I tend to think if that was
the case or even any one of the apostles
recanted, I think we would have record
of this. Why? I think we would either
from friend or from foe. So in the
second century you have like Selsa
showing up, this Greek philosopher just
going after the resurrection in every
conceivable angle. Later you have Pfrey
and if there was even a story or a hint
that any of the apostles had recanted,
one of them would have said something. I
mean Celsus makes stuff up about the
story of Mary getting pregnantated by I
think it's Panther Roman soldier. He's
willing to make stuff up. No hint that
there's even a story that he would use.
None from Pfury.
But believers also, interestingly
enough, you have kind of the Donatist
controversy that emerges about what
about Christians who at the point of
their faith is tested, they cave, can
they come back in the church? Can they
ever be in church leadership again?
Well, if there ever was a story about,
well, you know, didn't you hear what
happened to Andrew and he was brought
back in? So yes, it's an argument of
silence, but I think it's an argument of
silence with some teeth that we would
expect if there were even stories about
it. And there's not.
And early Christians did respond to
objections. They worked it they worked
it into their argumentation like uh into
what they presented. So, um they they
respond to the idea that Jesus is
performing they make sure they include
the response the idea that Jesus is
performing miracles by the power of
demons um on the idea that the disciples
stole the body. Like you can tell this
is an objection because they're actually
responding to the objection. So,
Christians are aware of information that
people are using against them and they
would respond to the arguments against
their position. And so I I guess it's
just you have nothing from the critics
of Christianity and you have nothing
from the Christians that's responding to
critics of Christianity. So it doesn't
look like it was just ever an issue that
uh people are recanting their faith. Now
that you mention it, you could take it
even further. Like the Gospel of Peter,
which is clearly not written by Peter,
end of the second century, exaggerated
content in there like a cross that goes
to the sky and floats, etc. But it's
responding to objections against the
resurrection. And so the guard story is
added in the second century. Well,
again, no mention of any of the apostles
seemingly, you know, abandoning their
faith or feeling a need to counter that.
The best explanation is that wasn't even
a story. Nobody was talking about it.
Nobody was aware of such a thing because
there's no need to try to counter it.
Uh, one more possible objection and this
this would actually be red flags if
you're reading Fox's book of martyrs
because Fox's book of martyrs uh will is
listing dates saying Philip died in 54
and this and that. I don't know how they
came up with that. Yeah. But we read the
book of Acts. We read the book of Acts
and basically if if people are we got
the martyrdom of Steven there. You got
the martyrdom of James James son of
Zebedee. You have multiple persecutions.
But why wouldn't uh why wouldn't these
martyrdoms appear in the book of Acts?
Well, of course, a big piece of this is
when Acts was actually written. And I
didn't go into this, but some scholars
argue that Acts is written in a way that
it's strongly hinting and aware of the
death of Paul, how it's compared to
Jesus. So, it's written after, but it
expects you to know that this was going
to take place. Others would argue that
it does include the death of Paul
because of course he hadn't it hadn't
happened yet. And so this places in the
early 60s, moves Luke back, moves Mark
back. We don't have to settle those. I
think what do we see in in Acts? We see
at the very beginning the apostles
proclaiming that Jesus has risen from
the grave as early as Acts chapter 2.
Acts four and five they are persecuted
in the sense that they are threatened
and they are beaten. We have Stephen in
Acts 7 who is clearly put to death for
his claim that Jesus is sitted on the
right hand of the father like the son of
man. Uh you have James in Acts 12. So
this is at least you know in the early
40s. If you I mean I wrote down multiple
chapters here that just kind of indicate
in Acts all the precedent that we have
is they go out and they keep
proclaiming.
Paul, interestingly enough, in 1
Corinthians 15, I did I did want to read
this because I thought you might bring
this up, explains that Jesus died for
sin, was buried, raised on the third
day, appears to Peter the 12, the group
of 500, James, the brother of Jesus,
finally to himself, although he
considers himself the least of the
apostles. He considers himself alongside
the other pot apostles as witnesses to
the resurrected Christ. Then he writes,
he said, "Whether then it was I or they,
the other apostles, so we preach present
tense, and so you believed." In other
words, when Paul writes this now in
AD55, probably 30 to 35 years after the
death, and the apostles had left by this
time, he says, "We still preach the
risen Jesus." And then he gets the early
church fathers and they don't list all
the apostles by name. But I think
there's eight sources up until AD 200
that say the apostles to varying degrees
believe they saw the risen Jesus.
They're witness to this and they go to
the ends of the earth proclaiming it. So
we don't have an account saying, you
know, interviewing Matias at the end of
his life. Do you still believe this? Are
you willing to suffer and die? No, we
don't have that. That would be really
nice. But one reason we don't is people
at that time were not asking the
questions that you and I are asking.
They're asking theological questions.
They're trying to survive. You don't
really have a church history until you
see who writes in the
3000s. But the consistent testimony we
have is from the beginning believe
they've seen the risen Jesus. They go
out face persecution. The death of at
least uh two we have in Stephen in Acts
7, James in Acts 12. 13 years after
that, Paul's like, "We are preaching
this as
witnesses." I think we're on pretty
strong ground that they continue to
proclaim themselves as witnesses to the
end, if not really close to it. And uh
so those those would be uh the main
objections that would pop up uh on the
on this issue of um what they're going
out preaching and so on. Um, interesting
because you have the myth mythicists and
they seem like they're basically
completely out of touch with reality and
scholarship as Bartman was uh happy to
tell them. Um, but also people who think
that belief in the core claims of
Christianity arose later through
legendary
development. We know from the creed in
first Corinthians that belief in Jesus'
death for sins and resurrection goes
back to the the earliest church.
Exactly. Very early. But also belief in
the deity of Christ goes back to the
earliest church. I mean when you have
the martyrdom of Steven and Paul is
there and Paul goes around persecuting
the church. Paul became a a Christian a
couple years after the death of Christ.
So this persecution is happening within
the first couple years of the church and
you look at what really sets off uh
people against uh the Christians and
what sets Paul off. You see the the
stoning of Steven. He looks up and he's
I see God and I see the son of man
standing at the right hand of God.
That's what really sets off Paul. And
then even when you get to to Ananas, he
says this guy is sent to arrest anyone
who calls on this name, calls on the
name of Jesus. And why would that have
bothered them? You call on the name of
the Lord. In the Old Testament, it's
calling on the name of the Lord. That's
prayer. And so they see these guys,
they're calling on the name of Jesus. So
they're treating Jesus like they're only
supposed to treat uh God. That was very
upsetting. But what what's it mean? It
means that's that wasn't something that
happened 50 or 100 years later. That's
in the earliest Christian church if
that's why Paul is persecuting them. So
we've got belief in Jesus' death, his
resurrection, and deity all going back
to the first couple years. Uh and in
addition to all that, we
have what the disciples were willing to
endure to proclaim these kinds of
things. What should people conclude from
your research on this issue? This is a
great final question. The way this is
often phrased and sadly I phrased it
myself somewhat this way in my early
days probably the first time we met in
2003 and I gave a talk on apologetics
and you came to hear me at William Lane
Craig's church I might have framed it
this way David I'm not sure wish I had a
recording of that actually now I would
play it and embarrass myself something
to the effect of the apostles were all
you know they died as martyrs except for
John they believe the resurrection
happened it's true therefore
Christianity is true. That just simply
is a
nonsequittor. We cannot conclude that
Christianity is true or the resurrection
happened from this. The last paragraph
or second to last paragraph in the book,
I say distinctly all this really takes
us back to is minimally the willingness
of the apostles to suffer and die. Some
of them die as martyrs. No evidence. Any
of them are caned. They really believe
that Jesus appeared to them. Now, how do
we know the resurrection happened? Now,
we're gonna have to look at the evidence
for the empty tomb. Now, we're gonna
have to look at the evidence, the other
cases for the appearances. Now, we're
going to have to consider naturalistic
hypotheses. So, this is one piece and I
think an important piece that they're
not liars. I mean, again, Jay Warner
Wallace says, and he's a cold case
detective because in every case that
he's had, people lie for one of three
reasons, power, sex, or money. Jesus was
like, "Give up your power. The first
shall be last." It wasn't about sex.
Clearly, Jesus showed nothing but
dignity and proper treatment of women.
He was single. Paul was single. And it's
not about money. They talk over and over
again about giving to the poor. I think
they really believe they had seen the
risen Jesus and I do too. So, as far as
what people should conclude here, you're
pointing out that this rules out a
possible explanation. So, we know what
the early disciples were claiming. What
are the the main possible explanations
even if you're including naturalistic
explanations? One possibility they're
lying about this. Um, another
possibility it's it's legend. it it
develops over over many decades or
something like this and myths spreading
and so on. Um hallucinations and so this
would block one objection and then you'd
have to deal with the other objections
in other ways. You'd have to show really
all all this all these people are
hallucinating about this guy in the same
way and then on the legend you just have
to show no this stuff goes back very
early belief in Jesus death resurrection
and deity is very early. So I guess a
final question is even though Fox's book
of martyrs is using late material for a
lot of these apostles and that would all
be in question and a more careful
historical investigation would lead you
to different conclusions. The evidence
we have should I have reached the exact
same conclusion namely my belief that
these guys invented a story to keep the
movement alive just makes no sense in
light of the historical evidence. I
think Fox's book of martyrs, he gets
some things right, is sufficient to show
that they're not inventing this story to
put themselves in harm's way. So, we
correct the things that Fox's book of
martyrs got mistaken. And I don't know
what sources he had or why. I think the
core of the argument that this isn't a
conspiracy theory. They're not making
this up. This is not for personal gain.
They really believe they'd seen the
risen Jesus, which begs the question, if
they didn't see the risen Jesus, you're
going to need to come up with a better
explanation for this. I think the heart
of that still stands. I think the heart
of the argument my dad was making more
than a carpenter still stands. But some
of the examples were just not as
substantiated in history as they need to
be. So, I have two goals in this. Number
one, I want to say to Christians, the
apostles really believe this. They were
sincere. They're willing to suffer. Are
you willing to suffer in the same way?
But also, I want to say to Christians,
like, slow down. Let's get our facts
right on this. Almost every week,
somebody tags me on Twitter where
somebody says, "Here's how the apostles
died." And they'll get like hundreds of
thousands of views. And I have to kindly
say, "You know what? We really don't
know this." And then all these
Christians lose their mind and attack
me. I'm like, "I wrote the book on this.
Let's get our facts right. We're losing
credibility, but don't be afraid to get
our facts right. I still think we can
trust their testimony. And what what
really fascinates me in all of this is
that um when I started looking into the
resurrection, just to respond to this uh
this question, it was I thought I was
going to it was just going to fall apart
the moment you start examining it. And
it's a it's a similar situation with a
bunch of these issues. You would think
if especially if you believe this stuff
is made up early on or later on, you're
just going to start looking at it and
you're going to find all this evidence
just evaporate and all these claims
evaporate. And yet, the more you
investigate, the more you realize, wow,
this this claim about Jesus dying and
rising from the dead. This goes back to
the earliest level. So, it's not
something that that arose later. Belief
in that he is Lord and that they're
treating him as God. That goes back to
the earliest level. And then here, why
should we trust these guys? Even when
you're applying the tools of the
historian and being critical and
skeptical, you still come up with the
same conclusion. Uh not all the same
details, but the exact same conclusion.
There's no way these guys are lying.
Amen. All right. Well, thank you, Sean
McDall, for clearing that up for
everyone. And guys, uh let's all try to
base our arguments on the evidence we
have available to us. And you know, if
you if you'd read that argument uh in
the past like I have and you've been
using it, uh that's fine. You went with
what you had, but we have more accurate
information to go on. So, let's make
sure we're uh we're all using the best
information in our apologetics.
[Music]